[Música]
bienvenidos a américa ce el magazine de
france 24 en el que tenemos las
historias y las noticias de nuestro
continente yo soy maría clara calle y
estoy en reemplazo de natalia cabrera
esto es lo que veremos hoy el ex
presidente de estadounidense donald
trump habría presionado a su
vicepresidente de mike pence para que no
certificar a la victoria electoral de
joe bayern esto fue lo que se debatió en
las audiencias del comité legislativo
que investiga el asalto al capitolio se
revelaron conversaciones y hubo
testimonios que perjudican a trump
incluso el de su propia hija
3 km selva adentro en la amazonía
brasileña encontraron los restos del
periodista británico don phillips y del
experto bruno araújo pereira una zona
donde reina la pesca ilegal y el tráfico
les contaremos cuáles son los peligros
del lugar donde los mataron
y en ecuador hay tensión entre los
indígenas y el gobierno de guillermo
lasso la confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas convocó a una protesta
nacional desde el 13 de junio en contra
del aumento de los precios y acusan al
ejecutivo de no querer escucharlos pero
el presidente se defiende
y comenzamos en eeuu pues avanza en las
investigaciones contra el ex presidente
de donald trump por el asalto al
capitolio que como ustedes recordarán
ocurrió el 6 de enero de 2021 cuando una
turba de republicanos y también de
extremistas se tomó la sede del
legislativo ellos querían evitar que se
aprobara la victoria electoral de joe
biden como mandatario el comité de nueve
miembros de la cámara de representantes
está realizando seis audiencias públicas
este mes para intentar demostrar que
trump promovió el ataque y que sus
acciones fueron ilegales paralelamente
el departamento de justicia también lo
investiga en una de las audiencias el
comité se concentró en como trump
intentó influir en su vicepresidente de
mike pence para que éste retrasará el
ascenso al poder de bailén los
representantes entregarán su informe
final a finales de 2022 veamos que
ocurrió en las audiencias
donald trump presionó a su
vicepresidente para que no certificar a
la victoria de joe biden como presidente
de eeuu esa es la conclusión principal
de la tercera de seis audiencias
públicas que realiza la comisión
conformada por nueve representantes a la
cámara y cuyo objetivo es aclarar cuál
fue el papel del entonces mandatario en
la toma del capitolio el 6 de enero de
2021 la hija y asesora de trump contó
que su padre habló telefónicamente con
mike pence en la mañana del ataque de
conversations pues la conversación fue
bastante acalorada era un tono diferente
al que le había escuchado antes con el
vicepresidente la escala se le antojaban
a otras personas cercanas a trump
reiteraron el descontento del líder de
la casa blanca estaba al tanto que el
presidente estaba molesto por la forma
en la que piensa actúa
en su intento porque se recontarán los
votos y se aplazará la posesión de su
oponente joe beimel tram le hizo un
llamado a su vicepresidente quien era el
encargado de certificar la victoria
electoral
y espero que mike pence salte adelante
por nosotros por supuesto si él no
cumple él no me gusta la pantoja que
fuera pero pensé se mantuvo firme y
luego de consultar con su equipo de
jurídicos supo que no tenía opción de
switch escucha esta semana que el
presidente donald trump dijo que tenía
el derecho de derrocar la elección el
presidente trump está equivocado pence
pública una carta afirmando que no
cedería a las presiones de trump y
durante el asalto la turba pedía que
colgarán al vicepresidente la audiencia
reveló que los atacantes llegaron a
estar hasta 12 metros de distancia de
mike pence y publicó fotografías
inéditas del vicepresidente
resguardándose un testigo secreto que
viajó con el grupo extremista proud
voice afirmó que habrían matado a pence
y también a la congresista demócrata
nancy pelosi se hubieran podido pero un
día después del asalto al capitolio mike
pence certificó lo que mostraron los
colegios electorales
joe biden era el nuevo presidente de
eeuu
otra de las historias destacadas en eeuu
se trata de un aniversario y es que el
programa daca cumplió 10 años desde que
el gobierno de barack obama lo creó el
plan protegía de la deportación a los
migrantes que llegaron a eeuu antes de
2007 siendo menores de edad también les
permitía trabajar legalmente esos
jóvenes se conocen en todo el país como
dreamers soñadores en español sin
embargo una década después muchos de
ellos siguen en el limbo porque no
tienen la ciudadanía el congreso hundió
una ley para regular su situación en
2017 el gobierno de donald trump intentó
tumbar la orden ejecutiva y ahora una
corte de apelación estudia una sentencia
de texas que dice que daca es ilegal por
lo que el programa no está otorgando
nuevas solicitudes
y la incertidumbre no es sólo para los
jóvenes migrantes el activista julián
assange podría ser extraditado a eeuu
aunque su caso sigue en disputa con
londres y especialmente con washington
el gobierno británico aprobó que el
fundador de wikileaks fuera enviado a
suelo norteamericano aunque assange
tiene dos semanas para apelar ante el
tribunal superior de londres desde hace
más de una década a la justicia
estadounidense lo ha pedido por 18
cargos que incluyen espionaje y
publicación de grandes cantidades de
registros militares y diplomáticos que
eran totalmente confidenciales
washington alega que esto puso en
peligro miles de vidas pero sus
defensores sostienen que assange le hizo
un bien a la libertad de expresión pues
la información que reveló mostró por
ejemplo como las fuerzas estadounidenses
mataban a civiles en las guerras de irak
y afganistán su familia incluso sostiene
que el gobierno estadounidense es
artífice de una trampa contra assange
hubo complot dentro de la cia para
secuestrar a julian para asesinarlo el
complot llegó tan alto que alcanzó a la
casa blanca de trump también se confirmó
de que había dispositivos de grabación
en la embajada de ecuador donde julian
pasó siete años los dispositivos estaban
grabando reuniones con sus abogados con
sus psicólogos esto por sí solo debería
ser suficiente para que este caso se
desestime es un enjuiciamiento de la era
trump que la administración de bailén
puede abandonar ahora mismo
ahora nos vamos al sur del continente la
policía brasileña encontró los restos
del periodista británico tom phillips y
el experto indigenista bruno araújo
pereira quien lo acompañaba en su
expedición por la amazonía este caso
despertó las alertas mundiales por los
problemas de seguridad que se viven en
el segundo territorio indígena más
grande de brasil de hecho las
investigaciones apuntan a que una red
internacional de tráfico podría estar
detrás del crimen paraguayo era un
reconocido experto que se oponía a la
pesca ilegal esta es la historia
3 km selva adentro encontraron los
restos del periodista británico tom
phillips y del experto indigenista bruno
araújo pereira ellos desaparecieron en
la amazonía brasileña desde el 5 de
junio las primeras hipótesis señalan que
los mataron
el pescador amarildo la costa alias
pelado reconoció que él y su hermano
quemaron los cuerpos pero aseguró que
fue una tercera persona quien los
asesinó el 5 de junio partieron desde la
comunidad de san rafael a atalaya de un
norte en el valle de javarí un viaje
aproximadamente de tres horas que nunca
terminó para ellos pasaron por la
comunidad de sao gabriel donde vive
amarildo está costa y se les vio por
última vez en la comunidad de la calle e
ir a cerca de donde encontraron sus
pertenencias esta región de la amazonía
es vecina de perú y colombia- y cuenta
con el mayor número de comunidades
étnicas incomunicadas también es el
segundo territorio indígena más grande
de brasil las autoridades creen que los
pescadores tenían una rencilla de vieja
data con bruno araújo pues cuando
trabajo con la fundación nacional del
indio se opuso a la pesca ilegal allí
solo los indígenas pueden pescar esta
área de aquí es para la pesca lo sabe en
verdad esta área pertenece a la
comunidad nada que ver con los indígenas
está bien una red internacional de
tráfico estar detrás del crimen muchos
le pagan a habitantes locales para que
pesquen ilegalmente en la reserva del
valle de javarí
especialmente el pez protegido pirarucú
la peligrosidad de la zona es mayor
también se cruza el narcotráfico la caza
furtiva la minería y la maderería ilegal
la situación de nuestros colegas
y esta es la situación de nuestros
colegas expertos indígenas en la zona es
desesperante están en sobrecarga en
shock agotados necesitan todo el apoyo
al igual que los indígenas es
precisamente todo apoyo
mientras las investigaciones penales
continúan el llamado de las
organizaciones es que el gobierno de
jair bolsonaro proteja esta zona de la
amazonía
sin medicamentos y con los precios de la
canasta básica disparados estas son
algunas de las razones por las que la
confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas del ecuador convocó a una
protesta nacional ellos culpan al
gobierno de guillermo lasso de no actuar
para que el sistema financiero alivie en
cierta medida la inflación y agregan que
por el contrario las políticas
gubernamentales les han exacerbado la
pobreza y han empeorado la seguridad no
resolverá todos los problemas pero debe
resolver los temas más sentidos
educación salud e institucionalidad para
la seguridad y el tema del ministerio de
agricultura y ganadería mientras de
usted con la decisión de los anteriores
gobiernos y usted con el decreto 95 ha
permitido duplicar la capacidad
productiva petrolera pero sin dejar
centavos para los territorios de los
pueblos indígenas presidente de la
república seguramente usted no compra
aquí en el ecuador o seguramente no
tiene la condición de ir a comprar en la
esquina en una tienda por eso no se da
cuenta cómo está la carestía de la vida
estos son los factores determinantes que
ahora
un pueblo de pie jamás de rodilla quien
hablaba era leonidas iza presidente de
la confederación indígena en 9 las
protestas él fue detenido durante 24
horas con irregularidades como por
ejemplo no le explicaron por que lo
retenían y lo dejaron incomunicados
según denuncian los indígenas el 4 de
julio habrá una audiencia para
determinar si será o no procesado él y
sus colegas dicen que la presidencia no
quiere conversar algo que lazó refuta
este gobierno siempre está dispuesto a
hablar a dialogar
con las puertas abiertas
sin imposiciones sin violencia que
afecta a las familias ecuatorianas la
presidencia también dice que emitió un
decreto para controlar la especulación
de los precios de los bienes de primera
necesidad y que coincide con los días
planteamientos de los indígenas pero las
tensiones en ecuador' permanecen
y para terminar la cifra de la semana
118 millones de dólares es lo que tendrá
que pagar google por discriminación de
género cuatro antiguos empleados del
gigante tecnológico estadounidense
demandaron a la compañía en 2017
afirmando que no le pagaba igual a las
mujeres y que por lo general les daba
posiciones más bajas una corte de san
francisco les dio la razón esta semana
lo que obligó a google a llegar a un
acuerdo con los demandantes ahora la
empresa tendrá un equipo de expertos
para mejorar la equidad especialmente al
momento de destinar los salarios y los
roles de trabajo
y así llegamos al final de aquí américa
recuerden que pueden consultar este y
todos nuestros programas en france24
punto com nos vemos en una próxima
ocasión
[Música]
porque la historia